five nights at Freddy's there's already
four of them but notice don't recreate
them there's nearly four of them soon
there might be five what's going on at
Freddy's what's this is a game that came
out august of last year initially at you
played the first one Johnson Mary you've
put him in prolific you played the
second of Thrones on a bunch of live
streams here at gamespot and they're
gearing up for a fourth game which is
going to be released on the anniversary
of the first game what the hell is going
on with the series Mary yeah it's it's
amazing that you can crank out four
games in one year and it's all basically
one guy Scott Lawson who like has
created this but it is he making the
same game every year or every couple of
months because from the outside looking
in it looks like it's the same like
basic mechanics for each one of these
explain what a five nights at freddy's
game is to like folks who might not know
right i mean this is this grew out of
such a simple concept which is that
you're a security guard and you're
checking all these cameras and you're
stopping these animatronics from
basically trying to shove you in their
suit which is filled with gears that
would essentially kill you but he he had
uh Scott did change up the game
significantly for each time so in the
first one you're this guard you get you
know there's about four main ones that
come and get you there's a chica who
typically comes oh that's Bonnie the
bunny she typically comes from the West
chica comes from the east and then you
have foxy that piece of [ __ ] I hate him
the most and then there's golden bear
himself Freddy and you know and they mix
it up in the second one there's a lot
more options there's like a balloon boy
and they start coming through the
ventilation systems so the chase cross
this is me and alexa playing it later so
you'd think that you'd change that now
you can put a mask on and protect
yourself but oh there's a musical box
that you have to complete you have to
consistently keep playing and then in
the third one then you become a part of
a the attraction so you're no longer a
security guard at the play
you are a part of an attraction at like
an amusement park and people are just
watching you freak out right so he is
going which is really fascinating
because the game itself no is it that
interesting not really but what makes it
interesting is maybe the lore and the
stories that these characters are
telling so in the first one there's a
lot of hints that you're actually
children died there was like a shootout
and like children died there and so
their spirits are basically inhabiting
these animatronics and then that's
what's killing people so that's what's
so fascinating and now they're like
starting to kind of really hone in on
that well then that's the lore that
makes this game so interesting to people
I don't really actually think it's the
mechanics it's it's it's just a game
play well it's it has this cult
following its that people delvin even
from the very first game is that they
kept diving into the stories like what
does this all mean and that we keep
writing about it but it keeps popping up
in the news because people are finding
new things in like new connections
between the games and that itself like
that thing that they've created around
it is actually kind of exciting is this
just basically the 21st century of you
know version of us like saying Bloody
Mary Bloody Mary into into mirrors
because it's like this whole like
creepypasta Slenderman era of games or
like especially internet myths which
kind of propagate especially with young
audiences so you tend to like these
games whenever you like look up like
twitch streams are like youtubers
playing them it's always seems to be
targeted at that's sort of like young
gamer who might not necessarily be
actually be buying this game with just
it's got this massive following around
people playing it that's that's such a
fascinating concept Danny it's like not
that the game itself is so terrifying
but what could be the recesses of your
imagination is really what the most
scary thing is about this series and you
could see that even like I don't know
like 10 years ago when the blair witch
project came out right what people like
the movie was not scary but what was
scary about it was the concept that this
might exist and so there was all this
lore on the internet about what actually
happened and did these people really die
and and there was always oh this was
based on a true story of all these
people died and so this is what kind of
happened with freddie is that people
started thinking that this was based off
of true stories people actually dying
and and and because of an electronic
ears and scariness up yeah yeah but like
that's what's interesting I think that's
what it peels to so many people and so
he's kind of like stepped it up a notch
in this fourth one you're going to see a
lot of from what you can see in the
trailer there's a lot that you can
gather it's being in a house now that's
really fascinating and so your home and
they're here in your home why would you
have animatronic things in your home
that's a really good question nanny so
there's two possibilities one would be
that this guy took them home after
Freddy's burnt down to the ground he
like he like collected them and brought
them home maybe you like you know any
whatever with animatronic game yeah
nothing's better than having animatronic
animals in your house too this was
something that you were learning about
and now you've gone insane oh okay in
your imagination and this is something
that you're just concocted in your brain
and it could actually make you I don't
have a heart attack or die so you are
now the kids watching the YouTube
streams who's now gone crazy and thinks
that maybe something like that well I
think that's you know what so they're
like these mini Freddy minions that are
on your bed that's behind use this is
like different so instead of cameras
there's been no cameras officially that
I can tell yet but there's a right door
and a left or in which they pay homage
to the original Freddy because chica and
Bonnie make a return and they're from
the same direction so again cheetah
you've got such depth of knowledge and
all this sort of stuff this is what's so
fascinating about those that people who
like paid attention to these things
might have to you right because there's
nothing really else going on I got what
I think one of my favorite things i like
is that the trailers are clearly just
made by somebody unlike vegas sorry I
looks like so budget but so why do you
think about like a game they're worth
that like nothing on scene they cost
nothing it's like with 75 bucks like you
can basically get like three of them I
think for something like twenty dollars
all three of them and hack like it just
do you think it's okay to release four
games of the same like even if you
created a genre on your own basically is
it still okay to release for games
within you know 12 months of each other
of course I and part of it is it's like
the DLC that we're getting with
something like The Witcher like that
you're not just your getting the main
game and you get a you get something to
experience and then you get a map pack
of your
month later and then another map pack a
month after that and kind of
interestingly kind of as a side note the
game was supposed to come out but the
next freddie was supposed to come out on
halloween he's pushed it up to the
anniversary of the first game and
there's going to be a free update to the
game coming in halloween cool and for me
I like I think that's a really smart way
for for an indie dev like this who's
who's created something that is really
caught on with people to keep getting
that attention and it will and keep
getting money to like keep getting paid
to make this game and if people are
still interested in and they want new
levels like well why not pay for kind of
what this is which is a substantial
update instead of like saying I'm gonna
make the entire game like what if he had
spent the past couple years making all
of these into one huge game like rice he
wouldn't have messaged necessarily have
even had the money to do that but this
has let him create something that's kind
of small the beginning and like oh this
has a has a following people like this
let me make the next big set of levels
for it and just keep going in that way I
don't think he had any idea if it just
would blow up the way it had I think
this was a surprise and you can
definitely see the budget in the trailer
I think he still has these humble
beginnings like there's this part in the
end for the logo kicks in and the
background is red and then just like
yeah it's like it's like who paid you to
do that like you know he just did that
and Alika sitting on the afternoon on a
track pad like awkwardly throwing it
together but no one gives a [ __ ] and no
you know what nobody even cares that you
know the graphics aren't incredibly
amazing the animations are clean yeah
well I heard that the original idea of
the animatronics is because he created a
game previously and people criticized it
because I everyone looked like they were
animatronic they look too scary he uses
a lot of Christian games actually so he
was like really a hard swing it is isn't
it I yeah and he said he doesn't like
have any regrets about it or anything
that was just something that he dabbled
in but because those animatronics were
so scary I said like one night he was
just like wow yeah what if I scared the
[ __ ] out of people and your weakness
into a strike that's right I mean it's
like a little cinderella story but with
like scary murder there you go five
nights at Freddy's it said on iOS as
well and they're apparently some sort of
movie in the works I've heard who knows
the internet that could all just be
nonsense as well maybe very well it's
true and last question for both you guys
do you think this is something we could
see on next-gen console Justin yeah I
mean I don't see why not like
part of it is just he needs to maybe
reach out to Microsoft or Sony or and
get them to reach out to him like this
seems like it would be in some ways a
really good fit for a console hmm it
would be something fun it would
definitely expand the audience may be a
catch game with any of these games to
player no but I mean a lot of times
you'd play them with friends but it's a
single operated game because everybody
can be scared when something comes up on
screen inside yeah yeah yeah and you
mean imagine the possibilities of five
nights at Freddy's with oculus and
actually learning behind you and soon
all right it's totally possible yeah I
rap for Morpheus five nights at Freddy's
a killer coming saga murder you actually
yeah I'm Morpheus version of [ __ ] toys
Freddy's that sounds all right all right
five nights at Freddy's it's out later
this next month august eighth and on the
pc love is the fourth game in series and
now you can check out the other three on
steam right now